Trascrizione: Piero Cavallo
Revisore: Sofia Ramundo
La Gen Z è quella generazione nata
a cavallo tra il 1997 e il 2010.
Siamo quei ragazzi fortunati,
che hanno subito le conseguenze
dell’attacco delle Torri Gemelle,
e della crisi del 2008.
Nati nel bel mezzo di una crisi climatica
e come se non bastasse,
vissuto una pandemia entro i 20 anni.
Possiamo dire di non essere nati
in uno dei periodi più rosei possibili.
Sulla mia generazione
ci sono due narrative:
la prima è che siamo degli sfaticati,
degli inconcludenti,
che pensiamo che tutto ci sia dovuto;
la seconda è che siamo dei ragazzi
sfortunati nati in un contesto difficile
che hanno bisogno di essere aiutati
e incentivati in tutti i modi.
La verità sta nei fatti.
Siamo nati in un periodo storico complesso
di difficoltà economiche,
sociali, politiche.
Ma la verità è che abbiamo fatto
tesoro di questo
e abbiamo lottato per il cambiamento.
Siamo nati con l’avvento di Internet
e dei social network
in un periodo completamente diverso
da quello dei miei genitori,
ma abbiamo usufruito anche di questo.
Abbiamo usufruito dei social network
per lanciare dei movimenti
che amplificassero il nostro messaggio
e che lottassero per quel cambiamento
nel quale crediamo.
Movimenti come Black Lives Matter
o Fridays For Future,
movimenti che sono nati
anche grazie ai social
e che noi giovani
abbiamo lottato insieme a loro
tramite i social network
per amplificare il loro messaggio.
La domanda è: perché sui social network?
La risposta è semplice:
perché i social abbattono le barriere,
abbattono i limiti,
perché i social danno voce a tutti
indipendentemente da chi c’è
dietro lo schermo.
Ed è questa la loro forza.
Basti pensare, per capire
la potenza dei social network,
che dal 2017 al 2020
l’hashtag Black Lives Matter
è stato ritwittato
più di 30 milioni di volte.
Ma allora pensiamo
a quale poteva essere la differenza
negli anni Cinquanta e Sessanta
con i movimenti per i diritti civili
nati anch’essi in America
proprio per lottare
per quegli stessi diritti.
Che impatto avrebbero avuto,
se avessero potuto utilizzare
anche loro social come Twitter,
Facebook, Instagram?
Cosa sarebbe cambiato?
Ma la vera domanda è: perché oggi?
Perché con i social network?
Ancora una volta la risposta è semplice:
perché le ingiustizie,
che siano siano economiche,
politiche, sociali,
di qualsiasi tipo, raggiungono un limite.
C’è una soglia oltre la quale
l’ingiustizia non può essere tollerata,
non può più essere ignorata.
E allora è lì
che arrivano i social network.
Perché i social network danno
una voce.
Danno una voce
a chi una voce non l’ha mai avuta.
O a chi addirittura una voce l’aveva,
ma gli è stata tolta,
completamente tolta,
dal dibattito pubblico.
Ed è questa la loro forza:
che non guardano chi c’è dietro lo schermo
indipendentemente dal colore della pelle,
indipendentemente
da quello che fanno nella vita.
Gli danno la possibilità
di lottare per i loro diritti.
La svolta digitale
ha completamente cambiato la nostra vita,
questo lo abbiamo visto
anche in tempi di pandemia.
E probabilmente cambierà in maniera
indelebile anche il nostro futuro.
Però è interessante comunque
fare un paragone
tra quello che è l’attivismo tradizionale,
quindi quello più prettamente
delle organizzazioni,
e quello invece digitale,
che ne abbiamo parlato fino adesso.
È chiaro che queste due tipologie
di attivismo non possono essere paragonate
perché l’attivismo tradizionale ha accesso
a fondi, risorse, personale.
Tutte cose
che l’attivismo digitale non ha.
Ma non per questo è meno efficace,
anzi è più efficace.
È più efficace perché l’attivismo digitale
non è ristretto a un’élite,
a un gruppo sociale
che può permetterselo
o a chi è direttamente interessato
alla materia.
Sono le persone comuni
a fare attivismo digitale,
io, noi, tutti noi
facciamo attivismo digitale.
Online si sta creando
un ambiente peer-to-peer
e si stanno creando sempre di più
delle conversazioni multi direzionali
che cambiano i temi generalmente trattati
nella sfera pubblica.
E allora qual è la chiave?
Grazie all’attivismo digitale
si sta facendo agenda setting.
Cosa vuol dire agenda setting?
Che noi utenti normali, persone comuni
stiamo influenzando
le scelte dei nostri politici.
Siamo noi ad avere un peso adesso.
Ma non solo questo,
non solo stiamo cambiando i temi,
stiamo cambiando anche il modo
in cui li si affrontano, i temi.
Ed è questa la chiave.
Tim Highfield ne parla nel suo libro
Social Media and Everyday Politics.
Lui ci spiega una cosa molto importante:
tutti noi pensiamo
che la politica sia qualcosa di formale.
Quante volte abbiamo sentito dire che sono
i politici che fanno le scelte per noi,
gli attori protagonisti.
Ma non è così.
La politica è qualcosa
di quanto più informale
e Highfield nel suo libro lo spiega:
siamo noi persone comuni,
tutti i giorni, a fare la politica.
Basti pensare che una persona,
un utente qualunque,
qualcuno di voi in sala,
posso essere anch’io,
con un semplice hashtag
può condividere un pensiero politico,
può avere un peso,
può esprimere un suo pensiero.
Con una semplice ricondivisione,
tutti noi lo facciamo,
quante volte l’abbiamo fatto,
con una semplice ricondivisione
su un topic, un tema di stretta attualità,
noi stiamo esprimendo un pensiero politico
e così stiamo influenzando
le decisioni di chi ci governa.
Quindi noi abbiamo un peso,
ma non solo questo.
Highfield ragiona anche su qualcos’altro
di ancora più interessante,
ossia di come noi,
persone di tutti i giorni,
con il nostro uso quotidiano
di social network
stiamo anche cambiando.
Quanto più noi utilizziamo i social,
quanto più la nostra partecipazione
politica si va allargando,
aumenta, cresce
il nostro uso di social network
contemporaneamente rende
la partecipazione politica più attiva.
Questo è qualcosa di meraviglioso,
se ci pensiamo.
Infatti la velocità,
il fatto che i social
siano così pervasivi,
la fruibilità dei social network
è qualcosa che sta cambiando
anche la società.
Infatti è interessante pensare
di come questi nuovi valori,
promossi digitalmente
possano indirizzarci verso una nuova
comunità, verso una nuova società.
Una società basata sull’empatia,
che spinga verso la comprensione,
la condivisione di cosa sia la giustizia.
E non solo: che amplifichi i messaggi
al di là degli individui
e delle singole comunità
perché sono i messaggi che contano,
non le persone.
Sono i messaggi,
quello che noi amplifichiamo.
E allora tutto questo è possibile.
È possibile se noi facciamo qualcosa.
Voi in sala, chi ci sta guardando,
noi dobbiamo fare qualcosa.
Io nel mio piccolo un paio di anni fa,
avevo 18 anni adesso ne ho 20
quindi non è tutto questo tempo insomma,
ho aperto il mio piccolo spazio:
Martaforfew,
che oggi è qualcosa di un po’ più grande,
su Instagram,
sul quale condivido temi sociali,
politici, etici
con altrettanti ragazzi della metà,
siamo molto giovani.
Però io, nel mio piccolo,
sono l’esempio che noi persone comuni
possiamo fare la differenza
perché contiamo,
perché possiamo farlo.
E tutto questo può accadere
a patto che anche noi crediamo
di non essere solo delle gocce nell’oceano
ma di essere molto di più.
E allora noi oggi abbiamo dei mezzi
che fino a ieri non avevamo
e grazie ai quali possiamo avere un peso.
Noi dobbiamo capire che abbiamo un peso.
Questi mezzi sono potentissimi:
con un semplice tweet o post
possiamo influire
sulle decisioni di politici e istituzioni.
Allora il mio invito è molto semplice:
magari potrete anche non accoglierlo
penserete: “Ma un ragazza
di 20 anni mi vuole dire cosa fare?”
Avete ragione,
però io vi chiedo perlomeno di ragionarci.
Il mio invito è di cominciare
a partire da oggi,
di non restare fermi,
non restare a guardare,
di non abbatterci di fronte ai problemi,
ma di provare a essere parte
del cambiamento.
Perché abbiamo visto cosa può succedere.
Unendosi e superando confini e barriere,
insieme possiamo fare la differenza,
possiamo cambiare per davvero.
Grazie.